raise your hand if you or your prospects
present with this distortion i'm busy
it's not a good time maybe in the future
anyone deal with these this is a busy
season for me got lots of stuff going on
as always we never disagree with
prospects because you're not in a fight
totally got it do you want this to be
something that lasts for the long term
that's a question you're like yeah do
you think that you're going to be busy
again in the future well yeah so you
want this to last in the long run and
you do think you're going to be busy
again in the future don't you think it'd
be best to start
now when you are busy because if you
learn how to do it when you're busy
you'll be able to do it forever i don't
have any time in my day you can't tell
someone in a sale hey take out your
phone take out your hours by week pull
it up oh look 22 hours on social media
you've got time so you say it
differently you say you know what i had
the same issue and i used to play all
the time about like how i didn't have
time to be successful do things i needed
to do my wife got so sick and tired of
me saying this she pulled my phone out
and she was like look i guess i just
found your time didn't i and you can say
it that way and then the prospect feels
better it's not like oh i've got to
overcome this one thing and then we'll
buy
you got to keep peeling